i read a headline the other day
headlines said
boy scouts welcomes first class of
girl eagle scouts my first thought was
no they didn't they they didn't the boy
scouts did not welcome
the first class of of girl eagle scouts
now i know that there is an organization
called the boy scouts and i know that
the boy scouts
now let's in girls
and i know that there's a designation
called the eagle scouts and i know that
the eagle scouts now have some girls
in it but it is not
possible for the boy scouts
to have girls in the scouts because the
boy scouts
are the boy scouts and the minute they
let in a girl
they cease to be the boy scouts
they might pretend to be the boy scouts
but they are not
they it is not possible going back to
our friend old old uncle aristotle as we
call him around these parts
you cannot simultaneously have a thing
and the opposite of the thing and have
them
be true at the same time the boy scouts
can only have boys in them i i can't
believe that we have to spend time
saying this
but i think the reason we have to say
this
is because we live in a culture that's
very open
and very liberal and very inclusive
and there are some benefits of this but
it can be taken
to absurdities and even conservatives
embrace all this kind of language we're
open-minded you know i'm a free speech
absolutist
i yeah man i don't i don't want any sort
of exclusion or censorship whatsoever
you you need exclusion
for societies to make sense i'm not
saying
unjust exclusion i don't want that but
you do need
just exclusion for instance the men's
bathroom
must exclude women simply for it to be
the men's bathroom it has to exclude
women
same thing is true of the women's
bathroom if the women's bathroom is
open and liberal and inclusive of men
then it hasn't become an inclusive open
liberal women's bathroom it just stopped
being the women's bathroom
the same thing is true of the boy scouts
if the boy scouts in the name of
liberality and openness
and inclusion and diversity accepts
women you haven't
created this more open boy scouts you've
just abolished
the boy scouts there's been a lot of
talk about
norm normal when are we going to get
back to normal
we're wearing masks we're not seeing our
grandparents we're not having
thanksgiving dinner
when are we going to get back to normal
norms define
normal we are we are edging day by day
by day that we let this nonsense go on
day by day by day that we wear the
stupid masks we are creating a new
normal
it is it is now normal to wear the masks
and it's abnormal not to wear the masks
and you're you can't have a society
that's free of norms
there's no such thing i think we like to
fool ourselves of that the left
really pushes this idea that you don't
need any norms nothing there's nothing
that we ought to do
there's you know we just do whatever you
want as long as it doesn't hurt anybody
else maybe
and the right has adopted a lot of that
same language
oh man i don't care what you do is it
doesn't affect me live and let live man
norms are inevitable norms are
inevitable
if if you are i think a lot of us want
to pretend that
oh man just who cares if the boy scouts
let some girls down who you know it's
not
such a minor issue well i mean it's it
is and it isn't
it's a minor issue in that i'm not a
member of the boy scouts and i have no
intention of sending my son to the boy
scouts
but it's a big issue in that we as a
society
are now saying you're not allowed to
have the boy scouts you're just
destroying those sorts of things
and if you follow this gender ideology
to its logical conclusion not only do
you get rid of the bathrooms and the
girls sports you get rid of girls
schools
you get rid of sororities you get rid of
fraternities you get rid of
anything that makes any distinction
between men and women
i don't know about you i find the
distinction between men and women to be
one of the things that gives
life its uh joy you know one of
one of the things that makes this world
kind of nice that men and women are
different i like women you know it's
sort of
that men are from morris women are from
venus that's kind of one of the
playful aspects of the world the
complementarity between the sexes
but we are now being told you can't have
that and if you want a society that does
still have that you have to stand up for
that
if you enjoyed that break from
disinformation historical revision
and screaming about the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button
so that you never miss another video
[Music]
[Music]